you know it is more unusual than you
would think that a writer becomes an
editor at least in this era it's not
unusual historically it happened to law
but at the New Yorker it's pretty much
at first
Ross was newspaperman but mainly an
editor Sean almost completely an editor
Bob Gottlieb became a writer really only
after he retired from the New Yorker
Tina Brown wrote a little bit as a you
know kind of sprightly feature writer
but came to write a book long after she
left the New Yorker I also had no time
to think about it I went from being a
writer at The New Yorker on a Friday to
the editor of The New Yorker on a Monday
I had no thoughts of this you know it's
not as if I were the third-base coach
for years and then became the pitching
coach and then became the manager or in
a newspaper you would go through any
number of steps before you became the
executive editor after long years of
both experience and competition so I had
very little time to think about what
this meant and the only salvation was
the fact that I was surrounded by
extraordinarily talented people
Dorothy Wickenden Pam McCarthy and reef
ender and so on and that the magazine
knew what it was about and then I was in
concert with that but clearly what being
an editor is about at the New Yorker I
don't know about other places is to get
the best work out of very very talented
people continually replenish a staff of
talented people with more of same to
give the magazine a kind of journalistic
and literary and even moral direction
ethical underpinning and to and to give
it a kind of sense of momentum and drive
and imagination and also to fire up and
to other people about what they have to
do putting very intelligent and talented
people in positions to succeed and get
the best from themselves this magazine
is largely about individual writers and
artists and so on coming up with what
they do best
now do I ask for certain things do I
push people towards certain things too I
think we need certain subjects covered
or looked at over time you bet but we
are not a newspaper we're not a news
weekly I try to see what these writers
are obsessed with and pushing
do I miss reporting I you know I'm fully
aware that you can't do everything in
life and each day get a little older you
realize that this is not just a cliche
but an absolute law of life if I thought
that my not writing either completely or
even a lot was a great loss to the
literary or journalistic world on the
scale of you know Philip Roth or John
Updike deciding that suddenly they had
to become chefs I wouldn't do it
the world can live without my writing so
much I do it a little bit i I energy
zelf I indulge myself by getting out of
the office sometime and going to the
Middle East or Russia or something like
that and and write about it but not very
often
once twice a year
you